to answer this question let's think
about what commits were present on
github and in your local repository
before and after get fetch when you
clone to the repository the latest
commit on it was Larry's command adding
the chili recipe so that also became the
latest commit in your local repository
of course there were other previous
commits but I'm leaving them out here
for the sake of space now you made a
commit adding a new spice so that commit
is also present in your local repository
and that's where your master branches
origin slash master still points to the
commit that was on the remote at the
time that you cloned after you cloned
Sara added the no cumin commit on github
but your origin slash master branch
won't reflect that yet so this is the
state of master on github now this was
the state of both repositories right
before you ran git fetch so if you ran
git log origin slash master you should
have seen that Larry's commit adding the
chili recipe was present but you're
committing a new spice and Sarah's
commit removing cumin were not present
on the origin slash master branch
if you run get status you should have
seen that your branch was ahead of
origin slash master by one commit this
makes sense because git log and get
status both run without internet access
suppose you were somewhere without
internet access when you ran these
commands your local git repository would
have no idea that the cumin can existed
so of course the cumin commit wouldn't
be shown when you ran git log origin
slash master and get status wouldn't
know that your branches were actually
out of sync it thinks that your branch
is just ahead now when you run git fetch
it fetches the no cumin commit and
updates the branch origin flash master
to point to that new commit your local
master still points that the new spice
commit like it did before so at this
point you have a local copy of the no
cumin commit saved and you can access it
via git log if you run git log now
you'll see both the no cumin commit and
the chili commit you still won't see
your new spice commit since that's only
on your local master branch now since
both origin slash master and master have
one commit that is not present on the
other get status will show that your
branch is out of sync with origin slash
master